so right here I have two potential
solvents that you might see some type of
a reaction take place in the one on the
right is a very typical one probably the
most common of all solvents this is
water and this right over here is dye
ethyl ether and we'll talk about naming
things like this in the future dates but
you can see what's going on right over
here you have two ethyl groups attached
to this oxygen between dye ethyl ether
but the important point here is to
realize where are these two solvents
similar where are these two molecules
similar and where are they different the
places that there are similar is in both
cases oxygen which is one of the most
electronegative of all of the atoms than
in both cases it's bonded to things that
are less electronegative and so that
allows that allows oxygen to hog the
electrons more often it has a higher
electron affinity and so you'll have a
partial you'll have a partial negative
charge for both for both of these
molecules on the oxygen side and you
would have a partial you would have a
partial positive partial positive side
from the thing that's getting to see to
spend less time to spend less time with
to spend less time with the electrons so
both of these we could call them polar
solvents polar polar solvents and a
general idea throughout chemistry is
that polar solvents are better at
dissolving ions because a polar solvent
you when you have kind of positive
negative charges things are flipping
around they're partially put there
they're connect there they're partially
attracted to the other positive ends of
the other molecule you can imagine that
it's very easy for an ion for something
that is positively or negatively charged
here to kind of get mixed in to the fray
now the difference between these two is
obviously what the oxygen is attached to
here the oxygen is attached to some
carbons here is attached to hydrogen's
and oxygen is far more electronegative
than the hydrogen czar it's a much
bigger differential than the case
between oxygen and carbon so in this
situation you will cinisi scenarios or
it is possible in a mixture remember
these things get really really messy
it's just there's a lot of just random
bumping in this coin
over here that oxygen is so
electronegative that it could often
times it can oftentimes take this pair
that's in this bond right over there and
if it did that you would be left with
you would be left with the oxygen now
having a negative charge it now has a
negative charge before this is let's see
I could draw up its valence electrons it
was 1 2 3 4 5 6 so now it's gonna have 1
2 3 4 actually make it draw a little bit
carefully so you still have you could
surround of say half of this bond so to
the hydrogen now you have these two
pairs so 1 2 3 4 and now it gains
another pair it got both of these
electrons it was already kind of sharing
half of this bond but now it has the
whole bond it now has the whole bond it
has a negative charge and then you have
the hydrogen while you feed distributive
its electron hydrogen is just a proton
it's just a proton floating around so
let me draw that so this hydrogen is now
just a proton is now just a proton
floating around so when you have water
prata is actually called a protic
solvent and then maybe another water
molecule might pick this up and take it
someplace in forming a hydronium cation
but this right over here water is protic
which means that you might have these
protons floating around these hydrogen
protons while diethyl ether is not
predict even in the case that somehow
one of the bonds you don't just have
just you don't just have little hydrogen
protons floating around in this and so
what I want to now think about now that
we know about polar solvents why there
pulls in polar but we have we also know
examples of protic and non protic
solvents let's think about how they
might which might be better when we're
talking about the types of reactions
we're studying so right over here you
might recognize in fact it's a good
exercise pause this video and tell me
these top three steps what type of
reaction is this and these bottom two
what type of reaction is this well in
this top one we see that this leaving
group leaves first and that this is the
rate determining step and then a
nucleophile comes in here and attacks
the carbo cation and attaches so this is
a substitution reaction but
the the rated with a nucleophile but the
rate determining step involves only one
of the reactants the leaving groups got
to leave so this right over here is an
sn1 reaction only involving one of the
reactants the leaving group hat leaving
is the rate determining step this on the
other hand but both the nucleophile
attacks and the leaving group leaves in
one step so this is a substitution
involving a nucleophile but both
reactants are involved in the rate
determining step now since both sn1 and
sn2 reactions need these ions floating
around you can imagine that they both
benefit they both benefit from polar
solvents so polar solvents are good for
both polar solvents polar solvents are
are good for both now let's think about
whether it's good to have protic or non
protic environments for either one of
these for either one of these reactions
well to think about that a little bit
more let's think about the types of
nucleophiles and the types of molecules
we're dealing with sn2 reactions in
order for this to happen you have to
have a reasonably strong nucleophile so
let's say reasonably strong reasonably
reasonably strong nucleophile and the
sn1 reaction well you already have the
carbo cation set up here the leaving
group leaving was actually the hard part
so you you could this could even work
with a weak nucleophile so even even a
weak nucleophile the real thing you have
to do is to get this leaving group to
leave and also if we want to remind
ourselves of some of the other kind of
the stereochemistry of the reactions in
a in an sn1 reaction it's actually nice
to have a tertiary carbon if these if
these are also carbons these little
circles I drew here that help stabilize
the carbo cation so this was a tertiary
carbon this would favor sn1 we also know
the tertiary carbon would not be good if
this is a tertiary carbon that would not
be good for sn2 because if these were C
you know carbon chains of some form
these three this purple this blue and
this orange thing then it would have
steric hindrance the nucleophile would
have trouble getting in so this would be
more likely to happen if you're dealing
with a methyl
carbon or a primary carbon and maybe
maybe a secondary carbon so here the
nucleophiles reason will be strong here
it can even work with a weak nucleophile
polar solvent in either case and the sn1
the key is stabilizing the leaving group
making it okay for the leaving group to
leave so what's going to help a leaving
group to leave especially when a leaving
group leaves it typically has a negative
charge well if there were a bunch of
protons flying around that one could
help stabilize this negative charge that
would help in fact this could then form
a bond with one of those protons it can
it can donate electrons to one of those
protons and so a protic environment a
protic environment a protic environment
is good for the sn1 while on the other
set while on the sn2 since you have
these strong nucleophiles if you had
protons flying around instead of trying
to attack the substrate right over here
the nucleophile would attack the protons
so you don't want that then this thing
won't happen so you want non protic you
want non protic non protic for for the
sn2 so hopefully that gives a little bit
of the basics of the solvents and also
nice allows us to compare these two
reactions in interesting ways